vers une indépendance énergétique et
industriel c'était le thème de la
réunion publique organisée ce mercredi
par jean noël barrot à
saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse la ministre
délégué chargé de l'industrie agnès
pannier rue nash et est venu répondre
aux questions des habitants le thème me
plaît bien surtout en ce moment avec eux
de ce qui se passe avec l'ukraine on n'a
pas du tout exploité encore les autres
énergies en europe qu'ils ont très
courant dans les autres pays notamment
la méthanisation
le solaire un échange sur des thèmes
importants qui préoccupe de plus en plus
les français l'enjeu c'est de développer
de nouvelles formes de chauffage et de
moteurs pour se déplacer qu'ils
n'utilisent pas les matières les
énergies fossiles c'est à dire de
continuer à développer du nucléaire de
continuer à développer des énergies
renouvelables notamment le
photovoltaïque et l'éolien mara et de
miser beaucoup sur la sobriété
écologique plan de relance programme
territoire d'industrie transition
écologique et création d'emplois la
réunion fut l'occasion de revenir sur le
mandat d' emmanuel macron et de se
projeter vers l'avenir dans cette phase
importante d'entre deux tours on va
essayer de passer ces onze jours qui
nous restent jusqu'au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle a à
à tendre la main à toutes celles et ceux
qui veulent eux choisir la une france de
l'avenir plutôt qu'une france de
l'impasse c'est à dire le choix de la
candidate de l'extrême droite ça suppose
évidemment de se rassembler très
largement de tendre la main aux
électeurs de jean luc mélenchon aux
électeurs de yannick jadot d'anne
hidalgo mais aussi de valérie pécresse
une réunion qui permet d'écouter et de
parler très concrètement aux personnes
qui auront à faire un choix crucial le
24 avril prochain